I mean let's just just go ahead I think
we being honest about that means they
had tampons and things okay that is a
level of preparation for what they were
going to do the corporate press is the
enemy of the people CNN also poy some
things stand out in their the mundane
necessity right you're talking about
tunnels we know these tunnels have
ventilation we know that they've been
known to have air conditioning they've
got this has all been reporting that
we've heard from the israelies over the
years but the fact that she's saying she
was held underground for more than two
weeks um that there shampoo there was
antibiotics there was a guard per
hostage in the experience she had uh
that there were Medics and paramedics
and obviously she is elderly the other
woman who was released also elderly and
had medical needs and that they had the
medicine needed and if not something uh
similar to replace it um it is pretty
stunning because you got to contrast
that with what's happening above the
ground right where there isn't water
never mind shampoo okay they don't have
water they're using toilet water there
is no morphine for any kind of uh
amputations antibiotics no right but
Hamas had stockpiled all of that and has
all of that underground and that's what
we're learning from her yeah and to that
point Ain and I want to play the sound
from her on this because it gets at just
how prepared they were for taking
hostages including at the scale that
they took them take a
listen they looked very well prepared
they prepared it for a long period of
time all of the needs for female for
that women needs shampoo
conditioner did that surprise you I know
everyone was surprised by the scale of
the actual terror attack itself but the
preparations for hostage taking also
seem to be a significant piece of the
plan yes when they say prepared for
things women's needs okay they were
therefore
prepared I mean let's just just go ahead
I think we've being honest about it that
means they had tampons and things okay
that is a level of preparation for what
they were going to do right and it shows
that they were going to take people of
all different ages right it shows a
preparation for that and you know we saw
that in the plans that we've seen taken
from the bodies of Hamas uh militants
who were killed in the terrorist attack
you know that it lays out what they were
going to do in every single caboots and
it also laid out very explicitly in the
ones that I've had a chance to read what
they were going to do with hostages take
as many as possible here's the communal
uh eating area in miss caboots this is
where they go this is how you get there
here's the map it's circled take the
hostages there so that was very much a
part of the printed plan and now you see
the other end of it the level of
preparation that went into it but again
in the mundane reality of having
feminine hygiene products shampoo and
antibiotics uh it is those very
specifics I think that are most
striking